hello readers let's talk about the idea
of genre in fiction genres are types of
stories that share similar themes styles
or subject matter so science fiction is
a genre fairy tales are a genre
mysteries are genre each one of these
types of stories has certain elements
that you gradually come to expect from
them fantasy stories have magic spells
and imaginary creatures romance stories
have lots of smooching mystery stories
have a crime and a person who tries to
solve it you can call these tropes you
can call these style elements but
certain genres have certain expectations
embedded in them the more you read of a
genre the more your expectations are
shaped for that genre when a story
begins with the phrase Once Upon a Time
and ends with and they lived happily
ever after
you know you're looking at a fairy tale
we all carry with us a unique collection
of impressions and expectations
it's your background knowledge your
schema if you think of your brain as a
closet then schema is the hooks and
clothes hangers inside that closet you
can put a new shirt on a clothes hanger
you can hang pants or a skirt on a
clothes hanger but if you wanted to hang
up a dress you might need one of those
fabric covered hangers so it doesn't
slip and if you want to store shoes in
your closet you might need to get a shoe
rack or one of those hanging shoe
organizers just as different clothing
items require different you know closet
infrastructure like hangers or shoe
racks your schema your background
knowledge informs the sort of literature
you know how to read
that's a weird sentiment to express I
think but it's true the first time you
read a book in a particular genre you're
forming an impression of that genre and
that impression gets refined or revised
with every similar book you read after
the first reading widely across many
genres of fiction expands your brain
closet let's be clear here not every
book is connected with every other book
and when you try to apply something you
learned in one story to another story it
may not work for example in 20th
century detective fiction there is a
recurring theme or trope that dates to
the 1930s the butler did it which is to
say that if there's a murder that takes
place at a fancy manor house there's a
good chance that the butler is the
murderer
but if you go into every mystery set in
a fancy manor house assuming that the
butler is the guilty party you'll be
wrong a lot famously in Agatha
Christie's Murder on the Orient Express
everyone did it every suspect in the
mystery is responsible in some way for
the murder in the title
it's an enormous conspiracy and Christie
plays with the readers assumptions as we
go through the story knowing that you as
a person who has probably read a mystery
before or who is at least familiar with
the form has an expectation that there
are only one or two culprits only one or
two people that did the murder to the
guy on the train and hey look I
apologize for spoilers for a story from
1934 but you can't make an omelet
without breaking some eggs you know what
I mean
anyway it's neat to look at the way that
an author can play with the expectations
of genre how an author might anticipate
a reader schema and play with that
something that blew my mind when I was
in school was the idea that Star Wars
was a Western or at least takes many of
its cues from classic pop western movies
let's draw a little Venn diagram all
right so over here we've got Star Wars
and over here we've got the western
movie genre here are some things that
Star Wars has that westerns don't have
space wizards like the Jedi and Sith
magic like the force or spaceships
here's something that Western movies
have that Star Wars movies don't by and
large have western movies have horses
they tend to have cowboys and they tend
to take place in settings like the
western United States and Mexico but
here's our overlap all right so both
Star Wars and western movies have bar
fights both Star Wars and western movies
have bounty hunters and both the Star
Wars films and Western films tend to
have a lot of
desert settings that could be the desert
planet of tatooine from star wars or
monument valley the US state of Texas or
the Mexican state of Durango in western
films mind you you can also make a
separate Venn diagram between Star Wars
and samurai movies because star wars
also borrows liberally from those this
is a great activity for analysis take
two stories that you love and compare
their theme settings and characters and
see if there's something you can find in
common between them you may discover
connections you didn't expect as I've
mentioned before good readers read
widely they read lots of books and they
let what they know about one's onra
their schema of the genre help them
anticipate and make connections when
they read a new book the more you read
the more schema you build the easier and
more interesting those connections will
become you can learn anything David out